we may have found the best Spider-Man
across the spider-verse Easter egg yet
well we didn't find it but if you're an
ultra Heat fan between the years of 2010
and 2014 you may have noticed it this
moment between spider Punk and Indian
Spider-Man replicated LeBron James and
Dwayne Wayne's famous boxing handshake
and one of the film producers did
confirm that this blank and you miss it
moment was in fact the famous handshake
the handshake moment wasn't the only NBA
reference throughout the spider-verse
movie we also got a sneak peek of the
new Air Jordan 1 high utility speaker
they didn't give us too much but what we
could point out is that it has white
laces with a potential white leather
piece that wraps around the ankle and
then there's also a parachute stash bag
on the heel people are naming it all
sorts of things Spider-Man ones third
spider vs Jordan Ones and the third Air
Jordan Spiderman